all right we move on tonight the
failures of the democratic agenda are
leading to more
and more violence on streets all across
the country
and while democrats try and run from
this truth and reality
and run from the destruction at the far
left extreme
agenda is causing the country and real
pain
inflicted on these residents it's now
undeniable
yet again this weekend a wave of
shootings hit the city of chicago
over four dozen shootings this weekend
in chicago
alone 50 plus people shot including this
sick and twisted attack look at this
a married couple literally following an
apparent
fender bender after the city's puerto
rican day
parade on sunday dragged from their car
and shot execution style pretty much in
cold blood
the man 24 year old giovanni arzuga
he's dead his 25 year old girlfriend
she's fighting for her life tonight
and police say no one is in custody
interesting i doubt you've heard the
name before right now
how is it 50 people are shot and most of
america doesn't know the name of one of
them
we've been running names and scrolling
names on this show
since when biden was vice president and
this was obama's home city mayor lori
lightweight
well you're a complete failure you have
let your city completely deteriorate
it's now devolved into a total war zone
you can't have
a pursuit of happiness in any way
without law and order and simple safety
and security
maybe focus a little bit less on
attacking republicans
and looking at the race of reporters
that cover you
and fueling divisive politics and maybe
focus on what's going on in your
backyard in your city
that you claim to care about you along
with comrade bill de blasio so many
others
failed democratic mayors and governors
complete disgrace to this country
and you're not protecting the citizens
you're supposed to protect
you're not being the public servants you
swore to be
if you can't protect basic safety and
security law and order
if you can't support the police and you
support no bail
well then it's time for you to resign
and let somebody in that will protect
the people of your city in your state
it's not just chicago new york city
prosecutors
get this and now dropping charges
against hundreds of rioters and looters
that were caught last summer during the
unrest better known as rioting
exposing yet again that this is a failed
socialist city and state
they're going to stalk donald trump and
well did he pay
every penny of every tax going back the
last 39 years of his life
but do nothing to save the lives of
innocent people
we have people on videotape committing
acts of arson
and looting we have their identities we
have their videos we have their pictures
we have all the evidence we need
we're not doing a thing you know are we
going to create a city
with normal common sense law-abiding
americans where they can pursue their
lives
what's going on in these democratic-run
hell holes
is an abomination it's unacceptable it's
preventable it's unconscionable
unfortunately it's not at all surprising
it's a natural consequence
of what democratic rule does to
everything around it
it works like clockwork far left
extremists take no responsibility
defund dismantle no bail laws and look
what's happened
take a look and many of the cities that
have talked about removing that money
like minneapolis and seattle
they've actually paused or slowed how
they were thinking about moving that
money
so this rising crime is not the fault of
the movement
it's actually the fault of the police
and this has been our point all along
why should we keep funding systems and
institutions that keep rendering
themselves
ineffective we should be talking about
gun control livable wages
fair housing education that's where we
should be moving the money
to to ensure truly safe streets
joining us with reaction radio talk show
host nationally syndicated larry elder
along with leo 2.0 terrell
you know larry i'm looking at your
reaction i'm looking at leo's reaction
larry i'll start
with you we do this every week every
monday we can come on the air
give you the names of 50 people shot in
chicago 50 people shot in new york every
other city
nobody knows their names larry nobody
seems to care about their names because
they can't politicize
it you know
sean and leo in 2007 when obama was
first interviewed by 60 minutes
michelle was interviewed as well and and
steve croft the correspondent said
are you worried about your husband's
safety and michelle said no
because as a black man barack would be
shot at a gas station in chicago
she wasn't talking about q anon she
wasn't talking about white nationalists
she's talking about the crime
in chicago it's one of those candid
moments and calmly harris in guatemala
talked about root causes
why aren't we talking about the root
causes here and they include as you
pointed out
the defund the police movement black
lives matter the lie that the police are
engaging in systemic racism
the pressure that police officers are
now under for fear of being accused of
racism
they're pulling back surprise surprise
crime has gotten up
and not least to which the major root
cause fatherlessness
not just in the black community but in
the hispanic community and in the white
community and we're not having a
conversation about that
at all and you know leo they don't give
an adam shift
they just don't give a [ __ ] seriously
about these lives
or else no seriously we would we would
know the names of the people
every weekend shot if they cared about
lives mattering these lives names were
scrolling would matter
we have a record number of police
officers killed in the line of duty this
year
this is all on top of last year's record
so the problem gets worse
but we'll hear about the one the two
cases that they can use politically
to bludgeon republicans why
why because they exploit and they use
black people
that's all they use them for they don't
use them to progress them
they don't use them to improve schools
laurie lightfoot is a political gangster
she's cut a deal she's not going to go
after the gangs she's going to
go after white reporters she's going to
go after gun control of
a wall-body citizen she ignored the help
of donald trump
but she's begging for help from joe
biden because she wants to make it a gun
issue
she wants to make it a pandemic a
pandemic issue but she
allows the gang members the career
criminals
to flourish in chicago she she got
al capone got nothing on laurie
lightfoot she is a gangster and she's
cut a deal
with the chicago gang and she's going to
allow them to flourish
and she's gonna at the expense of
minorities it's ridiculous you know it's
shameful the the three of us that i'll
end it here
all these names we're scrolling we all
agree their lives matter
but we're the only show doing it we're
the only show saying
every one of these lives matter we know
how to fix this
if they want to fix it they can fix it
they clearly don't want to
at some point they're aiding and
abetting this ongoing
death and violence and destruction hey
sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else